[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour tous
je veux vous parler de l'âme de demain
enfanté du monde elle en sera la fin je
veux vous parler
de moi
de vous
je vois un terrien
hd couleurs qui ne sont pas de moi qui
parfois me font peur sensation
qui peuvent rendre fou
ne change sur le fait
marionnettes
chanson les chemins qui mènent droit
dans nos têtes la bombe humaine
la tient dans ta main tu as le
détonateur juste à côté du coeur
labeaume m
ses toiles
par tiens si tu te laisses quelqu'un
bon chemin
c'est la fin c'est la fin de la faim
faim
[Musique]
nous
avec messe souvenir
[Musique]
j'ai allumé
mais chacun mais plaisir
je n'a plus besoin d'eux
pas relayé les hameaux
[Musique]
avec leurs traits mollo
balayé pour toujours
java part à ses rangs
non
rien de rien
[Musique]
non
je ne regrette rien
[Musique]
pour affaires
nulle my
tout ça m'est bien égal
non
réel t1
je ne regrette rien
c'est payé
ballet
oubliée
je me fous du passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]